welcome to new york every time i come to
new york i run into this problem
i completely misjudge the weather so
when i looked at the weather the days
were beautiful it was perfect it was
sunny
turns out it's actually quite freezing
and today we are going on a helicopter
ride of new york and they said if it's
cold outside
it's gonna be super super cold on the
helicopter
and guess what i don't have i don't have
a jacket i think i'd learn by now but i
have it
great news guys the jacket has been
acquired
what are you doing that youtube live
exporting a video
but hey just in time that's good it's
always at the last minute
you know and if it gets done it's done
and you you go on a helicopter and yeah
get some more content
and that's what we're doing
[Music]
we're here about to do the helicopter
ride
we're flying with fly nyon today and i
am
so nervous i don't know why i've been in
a helicopter before but i've never been
in a helicopter with doors off
there will not be doors on our on our
copter
oh god the fact that the doors are gonna
be off it's interesting it's gonna be
fun let's take a look
is it the size i'm not sure i don't know
if that's good or bad i'm not sure
oh gosh there's how are you feeling i
don't know where's the steering wheel
[Music]
any loose items
i forgot i'm attached to myself
here
you're keeping me young
[Music]
is
we were so
[Music]
i'll try so hard to fade away
but some something's forcing me
to stay
it'd be easier for me if i turn away to
flee
but there's something holding on
[Music]
this is so much fun i actually texted my
mom from the air saying mom
don't mad so mom don't be mad she
doesn't like when i do anything that is
uh you know remotely dangerous but this
actually was really cool
and with the doors off i mean you get
such an incredible view what did you
think
unreal my favorite part was statue of
liberty it was so cool
i mean i literally felt like i could
touch it reach out and touch it
it was unreal the worst part for me
though was
we had way too many cameras i didn't
know whether to film it was it was a
constant
vlogging camera big camera iphone so
many things
i have to go back each time like one
time for 4k yes
one time for wide angle photography one
time for slo-mo
and then another time just for enjoyment
with our own eyes
make sure you guys also go check out
sarah's channel you've seen her on my
channel before
and yes check it out sarah deichi
rhymes with peachy ops do you guys
remember the big deal that i made about
buying a jacket today because the
helicopter ride was going to be chilly
i didn't even wear it it wasn't even
that cold exactly
beautiful day it was beautiful
[Music]
so i think i finally recovered from the
helicopter ride yesterday it was such an
incredible incredible experience if you
guys ever want to do that i definitely
recommend it
they just said that they launched one in
vegas so the next time i'm in vegas you
better believe i'm checking that out
but now we're heading to do some press
today here in new york while i'm here
so let's go
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
guys we're in new york and look who i
found
hey we're here for the creator so summit
do you remember last year when david
blaine shoved something through his hand
that was for the first year so that was
two years ago two years ago
last year i got hypnotized show joey
do me a favor don't mess around me man
uh just say your first one you midnight
your last name
yaya you know michael
cruzafa gis
so who knows what's gonna happen this
year honestly oh no
bro is here hello joey and all of our
friends and we're going to lunch now
creator summit
[Music]
it's good i love surprises yeah it's
gonna be fun it's gonna be really good
though we're in creative something again
i'm so excited i know me too i know i
miss you
do i feel like you're not gonna be
honest i feel like i'm the worst friend
possibly
no you're like the best there are also
guys i try to be so there for them when
it really counts i will be but i haven't
missed so much stuff you guys do
it's okay it's okay it's so hard but all
right it's loud
so we just got through a bunch of panels
a bunch of speakers and now we're all
heading
to go to a glassblowing class are you
excited about this
i've always wanted to do that that's
real talk i did it in venice and it was
crazy and i
shattered my glass piece so it's
actually a lot more difficult than you
gonna go
okay now hold the piece oh shoot
oh god okay
okay hello what you got
you gummies you just eat lunch
they gave us a little goodie bag and i
went straight to the gummy bears first
oh no no that's okay
you're hitting something i'm just
concerned about the
car are we going to get there
who else is on this bus hello who else
is here
i don't know hello stacy hi joey i'm
sure i'll see you later when i'm editing
i'll be like oh i've spotted some people
and there's cassie
oh i can't wait we're just walking the
streets where are we we're brooklyn
[Music]
we finally made it we were stuck in
traffic for so long so we don't know
how this is all going to work out but
people are already making their glass
creations
yes they are so cool ready it is so
toasty in here
uh dare i say it's lit
[Music]
did you get a boo-boo
all right are you ready yeah man it's
hot in here
holy crap all right she's melting my
ball of glass now
[Music]
jesse thanks for filming anytime it's
probably the best video ever because i
filmed it
[Music]
so
i am so excited he's my hero
[Music]
strong is to carry us both out of this
this vlog has been absolutely all over
the place right now we're heading across
the river to brandcast and brandcast is
one of the biggest things of the year
it's basically where all of the
advertisers
come together in one room and we talk
about why they should be advertising
on youtube i know there's been tons of
discrepancies
and controversy over this issue which
i'm not going to get into here in this
video but what i am going to say
is i love youtube i love the community
and i love the creators and no matter
what happens
i love you guys you're incredible you're
talented you're amazing never stop
creating
but right now here we go see look this
is where we're going
over there i think we're actually
hopping onto
a shuttle i'm not sure we're gonna find
out i've destroyed this hotel room
already
let's go welcome aboard folks
this is cool this is awesome i've been
having such a fun time
[Music]
there have been some crazy developments
since we have been on this boat
trump is in town so they basically have
shut down
the entire side of manhattan and we're
the only ones getting a police escort to
brand cash right now literally a secret
service right like there's secret
service here
out there to chase us to broadcast cam
you believe
can you believe this is like sometimes
things that happen this is crazy how did
we
get here i don't know i'm sure we could
go back on our youtube videos and figure
it out
i don't know i think that might work
against us let's not do that
[Music]
is
[Applause]
it's great to be here in new york city
to celebrate
youtube or as they call it around parts
of new york
youtube
when youtube asked me to come talk to
you guys tonight
i said sure but with one condition and
that condition was
it would just be me talking
[Music]
but i hear it sounds awful out there
[Applause]
yeah it's all on me we're all changed
[Music]
probably should have opened this at the
beginning of brandcast but for some
reason i
completely forgot so now we're gonna
open my welcome gift
i got some slippers the only bottles
that look
look at this cute little jacket i love
it
good morning
today's gonna be a pretty busy day so
first we're gonna get started by going
to try to make it inside and still be
dry
first we're heading to film some stuff
was after us so let's go
[Music]
they will be so you guys can see them
and i'll put a link in the description
so you guys can check out his youtube
channel
um this is gonna be fun we're gonna be
talking about some really cool things
i'm not gonna tell you because
clearly that'll give away the whole
segment
uh ryan how you feeling about the air
it's fine
[Music]
today is taking quite the turn for
awful weather yes i'm ready go go go go
go go
go let me know so here at college
acceptance day it's a really fun mtv
show that they're putting on today
and michelle obama is also here
and i'm so so so so excited i'm so
excited i gotta be quiet
[Music]
and we are now going to turn it over to
miss hannah brockman
lovey ajaya and i just
[Music]
good morning guys hey because if you're
doing something that you love
the passion and the money will come and
that is something that so i did go to
school
and i went for video production
multimedia and my sister actually has
three degrees she has a speech pathology
degree a biology and a forensic degree
and but let me tell you what our job is
now
we make youtube videos insane and
so i've been on youtube for over 11
years so the job that i'm doing now did
not exist then
what i'm most excited about what jobs
are you going to create that do not
exist
now yes yes so good luck can we take a
quick can we give you a selfie
yeah yes okay make sure you guys squeeze
in okay
do you see yourself
we just got done on stage damiana it was
so much fun and we got to congratulate
everyone
and everyone is super excited for their
first day of
school like back to
oh school goodness i think this is
finally bringing my new york vlog to a
close i had so
much fun these past couple of days and i
can't believe it
that i got to meet michelle obama and
will smith like in the same
video those things have happened here
i'm speechless
i'm i'm absolutely speechless now i
gotta get a coffee and edit this video
so i'll see you later bye
[Music]
you